it was oscar wilde i think who said that
experience is simply the name we give to
our mistakes
the point being that you can't create
something great
without failing first sports art
languages writing name anything you want
to become good at
you won't ever make it there without
failing first
over and over and over again
and i think that this is exactly what
makes this scene here
during the along park arc so amazing as
it's the first time that we can truly
see oda improving upon a couple of
earlier mistakes he made
and taking a big step forward in his
storytelling overall
and so the chapters for today's scene
will focus around
76 to 81 and episode 37 of the anime
and you can also watch the scene in the
episode of nami
which by the way sounds a lot more like
nami having an emotional
outburst than the title of a move oh i
see what you did there funimation
however i gotta say that the original
anime here is
actually pretty damn good so you can
choose whichever you prefer
as always you can but really shouldn't
skip the recap by going to the time code
up here
and make sure to grab yourself a nice
cup of coffee as i get right here
why drink so much coffee you ask well
obviously
it's because i grind a lot
the scene takes place shortly after
leaving the baratier
and the straw hats chasing off the nami
who has stolen the mary to go home
after a first encounter of zorro with
arlong and the fishman
him luffy and sanji encounter nami on
the road to kokoyashi village
as we've already seen multiple times
during the arc nami tries to distance
herself from the crew
trying her best to make them leave the
island so she can finally fulfill her
deal with arlong
to free her village in exchange for 100
million berries
and of course also to protect her new
friends
however at this point she already has
saved both xaro
and usopp from the fishman's hands and
so when she tries to convince everyone
that she actually killed usopp
zoro starts towards her to once again
expose her facade
as he done before at a long part
sanji however misinterprets it as zorro
trying to attack her
and tries to stop him and while zoro
tells him that he understands
nothing you know nothing jon snow
he also doesn't care to explain nami's
true intentions to either him or luffy
and so once nami leaves for her home
sanji asks soro if he thinks that she
truly killed usop
and zorro jokes that she actually might
have after he called her komono which
means
small thing to which sanji immediately
becomes
infuriated again now this joke here is
especially funny in japanese as
zoro uses komo noi in this panel here in
the sense of nami being a small fry
who can't even let one person die since
komo no
literally means small thing however
sanji
immediately takes this as zoro referring
to her chest size
something that apparently not only sanji
but also oda took serious offense in
and so zoro and sanji start brawling
again
much to the despise of usopp who has
finally made his way back after escaping
through the water
and is caught between the two
seeing that usop is still alive all of
them now know for sure
that nami is in fact a good person
trying to protect them
then we get the heartbreaking and
actually quite bloody backstory of nami
from nojiko
that finally uncovers the full picture
we were missing since first meeting her
in orangetown
once we finally know what's actually
going on we see the marines arriving at
nami's house
having been tipped off by arlong they
have come to collect the almost
100 million berries that nami had
collected over the last eight years
in this moment nami learns from jen that
the entire village had known about
nami's true intentions all along
and that they simply were trying to give
her an easy way out from her burden
infuriated and feeling betrayed nami
storms to arlong park to confront the
fishman
who only laughs in her face and so after
what
happened the villagers have seen enough
and decide to finally take up
arms against arlong determined to get
revenge for nami
and themselves and when returning to the
village nami tries to stop them
but they've already made up their mind
and so after seeing her people marching
towards certain death
and being on the verge of losing
everything she has worked and suffered
for
the disillusioned nami becomes enraged
by the arlong tattoo on her shoulder
and in a heartbreaking and horrifying
moment starts
jamming her knife into it before she can
deal
any more harm to herself however luffy
stops her
it's in this moment of greatest
desperation
that she finally turns to luffy and in
an extremely
emotional moment asks him for help
it's heartbreaking and when luffy
enthusiastically agrees
and makes his march to arlong park with
sanji zorro and usopp
it's enthralling to know that arlung
will finally get the justice he deserves
[Music]
as i mentioned at the beginning of this
video there is one thing in particular
that makes this scene and the
overarching oblong park arc
so special in the larger context of the
narrative
and that is the storytelling here and
how oda placed this arc into the
structure of the story
i really believe that arlong park is a
gigantic step forward in terms of oda's
storytelling skills
and improves on a number of elements in
the earlier east blue arcs
what makes the climactic moment with
nami so powerful here
is that it's been worked towards for a
long time in a way you could even say
that arlong park is the very first mini
saga of the story
that has been spun into most of the
previous arcs
it's of course not comparable with for
example the yonko saga
spanning from fishman island all the way
to wano
as the buildup's way smaller and also a
lot more subtle
however it's the very first time that
oda proves to us his talent for
long-term planning and foreshadowing
that become more and more pronounced
throughout the plots
the hints pointing to oblong park are
relatively small
but they're there for instance when
luffy first meets
nami she tells him that she's going to
earn 100 million berries for a certain
purpose
or during the bharatiya arc nami
abandons the crew and steals the merry
after seeing a bounty poster of a
mysterious pirate named arlong
it's definitely not much but it gets our
attention
and these long-term references
culminating in our long park
create way deeper resonance and impact
than many of the earlier mini arcs
and so it's not for nothing that it's
still one of the most popular one piece
arcs of all time
because with arlon park oda proves to us
that you don't necessarily need
world shattering history changing stakes
in order to be invested in the conflict
at hand
but that all you need is some damn good
storytelling
now there are two well maybe two and a
half things in particular that i think
that oda has improved on in this arc
compared to the first four backstory
battle and placement
for zara and usopp oda had yet to figure
out
how to incorporate a backstory properly
into the narrative
both are revealed after the events of
the arc already have taken place
and feel almost like an afterthought to
the central conflicts
however when reaching the baratier i
think he slowly began to understand the
importance of tying the backstory of a
new character
into the conflict at hand and so by
learning about sanji's past and his
connection to zeph
we understand why it's important to him
to protect the bharatiya and his mentor
but it still has no real connection to
neither don creek nor
mihawk and so on my first watch of the
series i was a little confused and
worried that nami
wasn't even gonna get a standard
backstory like the other crew members
the patterns seem pretty clear luffy and
co
land on an island find a new crew member
we get a glimpse of their backstory
luffy defeats the bad guy and the crew
moves on plus one
and so i began to worry that nami would
be glossed over and underused like
female characters often are in this type
of series
however as it turns out by arlong park
oda finally had figured out
how to use the character's backstories
to his advantage
and so i was relieved when i realized
that arlong park was about to be nami's
arc
and that we'd finally get to see her
backstory and
what a backstory it was and so when
luffy finally defeats arlong and
destroys the grotesque castle that he's
built for himself
it isn't just vaguely related to nami's
backstory
it's the resolution to it not only did
luffy knock out the man who had
tormented and tortured her for the past
8 years of her life
but he destroys the very room that nami
has worked in for so many years
along with arlong park itself the symbol
of oppression
that had been looming over the citizens
of the island all this time
the events of olong park and the reveal
of nami's backstory
have to occur simultaneously because
they are essentially the same conflicts
one can't happen without the other and
from here on out
oda pretty much has carried the success
of this formula
into every single new arc where we meet
a new straw hats
chopper's connection to wapol vivi's
connection to crocodile
frankie's and robin's connection to the
world government
brook's connection to moria and finally
jimbay's connection to hodie and arlong
who's actually name dropped for the very
first time here in this arc
going full circle and to illustrate this
point a bit further even
when you look at robin's rescue at ns
lobby it actually comes
pretty close to this moment here
arguably a bit better and more
creatively executed
but pretty much the same formula trying
to distance themselves from the crew to
protect them
but ultimately accepting luffy's love
and asking to be saved
plus the epic walk and that already
brings me to my second or
actually first and a half point one and
a half points
1.5 points to my next point
placement
this scene between luffy and nami and
the other straw hats
is not an isolated string of events but
is reused and referenced by oda
over and over again and woven into the
larger fabric of the story
the events of oblong park keep being
relevant as the story progresses
as we meet more and more fishermen like
jinbe and tom
that actually seem to be anything but
the cruel monster that along represents
and so once we arrive on fishman island
after the time skip
oda turns our entire perception of the
ark on its head
when aolong and his men were introduced
as the very first
non-human race oda made us believe that
the fishmen were highly
spouting racial slurs and based their
cruel behavior towards nami and her
people
on their racial superiority however we
very quickly learned that the truth is
actually the exact opposite
the fishmen are actually the ones who
have suffered for centuries under racial
oppression and slavery by the hands of
the humans
and arlon and his men were the pitiful
and dark result of discrimination and
prosecution
with a quite tragic backstory and so
looking back
the once intimidating and seemingly
unbeatable fishmen
now look like weak and helpless rejects
who
try to take revenge on the humans by
leaving the grand line and enforcing
their will
on some of the most vulnerable people
they could find
arlong park turns out to be a quite
depressing imitation of saba odi park
as an aspirational dream of the young
and oppressed
but still full of hatred fishmen looking
for more acceptance this twist
is actually already well foreshadowed by
oda through the character of hachan
who's already hinted at to be nice and
naive when bringing zorro into the
village
despite him being human and coming
strolling out of arlon park
later we get an entire cover story for
him
and finally meet him again as an ally at
zabaodi
and so the entire aolong park arc feels
like an organic piece of narration and
world building in the larger context of
the story
that makes this moment between nami and
the straw hats
just the more powerful something that is
missing from previous arcs
though oda admittedly found ways to
reference them again later on during
luffy's backstory or
sanji's blackmail during whole cake
islands but it's not quite as smooth as
arlong park
since oda clearly already had the plot
threat with the fishman
planned and foreshadowed here now the
third thing that i think oda does
wonderfully in the scene
is battle
something that this scene manages to do
way better than the uggs before
is bring out the straw hats as a real
crew and collective
up until now it was mostly luffy beating
someone's ass and occasionally
zorro jumping in to fight someone else
since
one piece is a world of pirates though
it just makes sense that each villain
would have a crew of their own to
contend with
but arlong park is the very first arc
that truly utilized this to its fullest
capacity
as zorro sanji and usop all face off
against a different one of arlon's
officers
and get the chance to prove themselves
as worthy members
despite being grievously wounded by
mihawk zoro was able to stay on his feet
long enough to defeat [ __ ]
and then fend off arlong while sanji
goes to save the stock luffy
and he's also capable enough to fight
off a fishman in the water and come out
alive
and even usopp who is at the time
clearly the weakest of the group
manages to take down one of arlon's
strongest men
and then of course luffy also beats
arlong
and all of it started with the epic walk
to a long park in this moment here
and the reason that this works so well
here goes beyond nami's salvation
hinging on each individual straw hat
victory
because each member in this arc also has
something to prove for themselves
each victory is not just a win for the
cause but validation for the individual
against
an enemy that has been built up as the
strongest so far in the story
once again we see this pattern repeated
on a larger scale in ana's lobby
where robin's salvation is dependent on
each straw hat winning
but each of them also trying to prove
something for themselves
[Music]
as you can see storytelling is a
gigantic
factor in what makes this scene so
fantastic
and of course that goes for all other
scenes after this as well
but i really thought it was worth
pointing it out here as it was such a
big step up from previous arcs
for instance the double twist oda does
with nami's character
where at first she tries to pretend like
she was evil
but then turns out to have been her true
self all along
as well as the way that luffy and zorro
show her that she can't fool them
with zorro jumping into the water and
making her save him
as well as luffy simply waiting for her
to ask him for help
are fantastically portrayed in the
dialogue and body language
and besides arlong park and luffy
destroying nami's room
there's also a lot more great symbolism
here
for instance nami's anger first at her
helplessness against evil and then
against the evil itself
takes the form of her dagger which oda
explicitly in a quite gory way shows her
stabbing straight into her tattoo
a symbol of her emotional imprisonment
and arlong's tyranny
similarly nami crying and asking for
help
after promising as a child that she
would never cry again and ask
anyone for help shows us how luffy
manages to save
people and give them hope and in this
scene here he of course shows this
especially through his straw hat
that is luffy's biggest treasure and
that he will let no one under
any circumstances wear and yet he gives
it to nami
showing how much he trusts in her and
that she is just
important to her as his hat and i think
that this
encompasses really well everything what
makes this moment here
so fantastic and since we learned in
this video
how oda drastically improved his
backstories in this arc
why not test this theory right with the
next straw hats
[Music]
because this is not only one of my
favorite moments
but also has been requested a bunch of
times by now
which i think shows that you guys have
real great tastes
and so we'll be looking at that scene in
the next video
so stay tuned for that thanks guys
[Music]
peace